à partir du moment on a cru voir à tort
ou à raison
l'épiscopat
pas toujours pas à chaque fois mais il
est arrivé il serait arrivé que
l'épiscopat couvre c'est à dire qu'à un
moment tel prêtre soupçonné soit laissé
à son poste en contact des enfants ce
qu'on appelle mettre la poussière sous
le tapis ça ce serait typique de
l'église catholique alors pour les
raisons peut-être qui a évoqué anne
soupa ou pas mais ça est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est vrai est-ce que c'est
typique des l'église catholique j'en
sais rien ce qui est sûr le déni il est
incontestable des need existe quatre
lits qu'il est incontestable est debout
là bas voulu dissimuler pour protéger
l'institution c'est indéniable même les
épais qui le reconnaissent pas tous mais
la grande majorité des évêques le
reconnaissent c'est ça me parait samba
essentiel après que toute institution
cherchent à se protéger est-ce que c'est
propre à l'église catholique est là en
moins le courage d'essayer de faire le
ménage et de voir la vérité en face
douloureusement difficilement après
longtemps d'erreurs mais elle le fait et
je crois que toute institution devrait
s'interroger son âme et la honte elle se
protège par rapport à tout ça et mais la
poussière sur le tapis ça n'est pas
réservé disent catholiques
[Musique]